there was a fake list yeah and I'm on
it so you you you you were on the island
I was apparently I I don't know they
said I was on the island they said I'm
and I'm like I don't go
anywhere if the story was about a bus
it maybe but it's like you know so I'm
just going to say you know and there's
been a lot of stuff recently I don't
know what I've done to anybody but
apparently there are a lot of these
these kind of sites
that are what do you call them they or
satire sit sites but people don't
realize that they can be harmful oh yeah
whippy that sure sounds like the sort of
thing that somebody who is best friends
with Jeffrey Epstein would say h this
whoopy down there on the island with all
that I don't think so actually there are
fake lists I can't believe I have to
agree with The View today